deep down inside I feel like you're a  woman how in the world do you believe  everything a man believes you should  have nuanced positions that's the beauty  of the masculine feminine where you  there's similarities and there's  differences so when I hear a logical  woman I definitely expect to hear her to  communicate things that the logical male  and female understands but I also expect  because she's a feminine individual and  you believe men and women are different  so therefore if men and women are  different and both of them are  communicating their ideas there's going  to be differences and nuances to their  ideas